إن أجمل شيء في كرة القدم
هو لعب كرة القدم وبصرف النظر عن ذلك ، يمكنك
أن تدرب ،
إنه أمر شائع جدًا في
لاعبي خط الوسط عندما تكون
في منتصف اللعبة ، فأنت بحاجة إلى التفكير في
لعبتك ولكن عليك
التفكير في المجموعة التي تحتاجها
فكر في الفريق وكيف يمكنك مساعدة
الجميع.
لكي أكون مديرًا
[موسيقى
] بدأت هنا ، لذا كان من
المنطقي تمامًا أن أعود إلى جذوري ، فنحن
فخورون حقًا بالمكان الذي أتينا منه
وكيف نتعامل مع الأشياء التي كنا نتحدث
عنها عن عقلية الماضي وأنت تعلم أنهم
إنهم عمال شاقون رائعون نريد أن
نكون منافسين على المستوى الأعلى ولكننا نريد
للاعبين الشباب الذين من المنطقة
أن يكونوا قادرين
على اللعب في المستوى الأعلى أيضًا
ولهذا لدينا برنامج مكثف للغاية
لتطوير
التقدم  كيف  لإنشاء ليس فقط لشراء
لاعبين رائعين لإنشاء لاعبين رائعين ،
وهذه العملية ممتعة للغاية ،
أعتقد أن ميكيل لديه المعرفة بأن
لديه شغفًا
يتمتع بالأصالة ليكون قادرًا
على القيام بأشياء رائعة
ولكن ليس من السهل الدوري الممتاز
إنها تتطلب قدرًا كبيرًا من المنافسة ،
لكنني أعتقد أن ميكل يمكنه القيام
بعمل رائع
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
وفي أي مكان أذهب إليه ، أكون هنا في سان
سيباستيان ومشجعي ليفربول يوجهون التحية
إلي وما زلت أشعر بهذا الدعم
وبالنسبة لي
الشعور بأن هذا على قيد الحياة ، إنه أمر
رائع ، وفي الوقت الحالي ، يقوم جورج بعمل رائع ،
لذا أعتقد أن المهمة قد تم إنجازها
في الوقت الحالي ،
لكن من المؤكد أن ليفربول هو
أفضل نادٍ بالنسبة لي ، إنه مميز جدًا جدًا ،
لست في عجلة من أمره  الوصول
إلى المستوى الأعلى ، أعلم أنه في مرحلة
ما إذا واصلت الأداء الجيد وأعتقد
أنني قد أفعل
ذلك ، فسيأتي
[موسيقى]
أنت